so in one word and only one word Josh
what is your professional style urgent
I'm here with Josh summer the founder of
the chordoma foundation for people don't
know what is core doma cordella is a
rare type of bone cancer that occurs in
the head and along the spine and you
were personally diagnosed with this I
was about six years ago when I was an
undergrad at Duke I found out that I had
a tumor right in the very center of my
head and it turns out after surgery that
it was there was this rare disease that
I'd never heard of called chordoma and
in what were your what were your chances
given to you at that at that point so
what I was told is that core doma has an
average survival of about seven years
that patients who are diagnosed with it
have a cure rate of about thirty percent
and frankly being 18 years old and
having a lot to look forward to i didn't
want to accept those statistics so you
dropped out of school I did yeah well
first I it turns out that the only lab
in the country that had a federal grant
study khordam happened to be at Duke
where I was at the time well how lucky
is that you couldn't get I mean it was
total serendipity I mean unlucky but
lucky I suppose that's exactly right
certainly unlikely and I was studying
engineering at the time didn't know
anything about cancer research but I
ended up joining that lab and you're
really taking an interest in the work
making some good progress what we found
was that our hands were tied in many
ways we didn't have enough funding we
didn't have the materials that we needed
to study tissue cell lines animal models
like the real the subjects of our
research and so I realized in order to
solve those problems and bring more
researchers into the field that we would
have to start an organization to lead
that process and you've raised a fair
amount of money about 2.7 million
dollars thus far and how have you gone
about doing that it's been very
grassroots you know their core doma
patients all over the country who are
doing golf events and bike rides and
things like that our average donation
size is about three hundred and fifty
dollars but you know we've been very
fortunate and that we've built a strong
board we have a lot of very dedicated
supporters and so increasingly we're you
know people are making larger and larger
gifts right and how rare is the cancer
it's exceedingly rare that the incidence
is about one in a million one in a
million to their like 400 people in the
US who have each year there's about 300
people to get diagnosed oh and at any
given time there's about 2,500 people
have it right okay have you met many of
them a lot of them yeah so we're in
touch with about 700 cordova patients
and another thousand or so family
members we put on international court
AMA community conferences so patients
from all over the world come you know
get to meet one another oftentimes it's
the first time that they've met anyone
else that has the disease and that's
that's been actually one of the best
parts of this whole journey is just
getting to connect with other people who
are walking it you know in your shoes so
to speak and you used that money to fund
research I believe you said 11 different
labs that's right we funded research in
11 different labs we've set up a biobank
to collect chordoma tumor tissue from
across the country we've developed new
cell lines and animal models which are
really critical for all aspects of
research and in fact we've set up a cell
line repository that has distributed
cell lines to 52 different labs
including four different pharmaceutical
companies and in doing so we've
leveraged millions of dollars worth of
research focus that on encore dama our
other PR the other sufferers of rare
cancer other people doing similar things
or not really it really varies I mean
there there are some some organizations
that are doing similar things and you
know in many ways we were standing on
the shoulders of giants of organizations
that are farther along than we are but
they're arches I would point to the
multiple myeloma Research Foundation as
a great example but you know their
diseases is 40 times more common than
chordoma and while the challenge they
face are similar there are also some
differences there's other i would say
organizations that that are focused on
diseases that are of similar rarity one
is called the adenoid cystic carcinoma
Research Foundation and we're really i'd
say blazing parallel paths doing many of
the similar things learning from one
another but the reality is there's
hundreds of rare cancers and there's a
small number of organizations that are
really focused on proactively driving
forward science and those diseases and I
think there's an opportunity because
many of these cancers face the same
challenges for us to work together to
solve the problems you know solve them
once and not reinvent the wheel for for
each cancer over and over again she
actually just have a minute left so if
you were to give some advice to somebody
who was young he's 18 19 20 years old
that is diagnosed with a
potentially deadly disease that's got to
be kind of a I would imagine that's very
scary it's a very sort of lonely
experience what would you tell them I
would say that you have a lot of power
there's a lot of problems that aren't
going to get solved on their own that
scientists aren't going to be able to
solve on their own that drug companies
aren't going to be able to solve on
their own and as a patient or as a
patient organization you know our sole
focus is driving forward research to
find a cure and I think there's an
important role for patients to play
whether it be by starting an
organization or supporting an
organization that is really being
proactive about driving forward research
in a particular disease so I would say
to anyone who is diagnosed with any sort
of rare disease get involved with a
patient advocacy organization and be
smart about the way you're you're
focusing the research dollars not just
offering money for you know for any
research project but come up with a
research plan and be proactive and
strategic about driving that plane
forward